DOZIER: So welcome to today's Council on Foreign
Relations meeting on "Women in the Armed Forces:
The Future of the Military."
We're starting things promptly at 8:30 and
1/2.
Today we have with us Juliet Beyler, who is
the principal director of force resiliency
of the Office of the Under Secretary of Defense
for Personnel and Readiness at the Pentagon.
Gayle Tzemach Lemmon; she's the senior fellow
for women and foreign policy at CFR and author
of "Ashley's War: The Untold Story of a Team
of Women Soldiers on the Special Ops Battlefield,"
just now out in paperback.
And she said that three of the women from
the book are in the room, so we will be putting
you on the spot later.
And we also have Agnes Gereben Schaefer, who
is a senior political scientist at the RAND
Corporation and has done many studies on the
issue at hand.
So, we start with the first question.
Last December, Secretary of Defense Ash Carter
opened all combat roles to women.
Can you give us an update?
Where does it stand?
BEYLER: Sure, absolutely.
Thank you.
DOZIER: Bringing policy into action.
BEYLER: Yes, absolutely.
So, good morning, everyone.
Thank you for having me.
So, as Kimberly said, so the secretary announced
in early December that he was opening all
remaining positions to women.
And during that announcement, he directed
that the services kind of develop detailed
implementation plans to come back to him by
the 1st of January, explaining exactly-articulating
exactly the details on how they were going
to make this happen.
We stood up an implementation group that was
co-chaired by the deputy secretary of defense
and the vice chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff, and they combed through-we had several
meetings with the vice chiefs and the leadership
of the department, looking through each of
the services.
They cross-briefed each other on the details
of the plan, looking to make sure that they-there
were no issues, and that everything was covered,
and that they had all addressed all of the
secretary's concerns that were laid out in
his December memo.
Then, in 9 March, the secretary, we briefed
those up to him.
He reviewed all of the plans personally himself,
and he approved all of the plans on 9 March.
And he said everyone go forth and open everything
no later than April 1st, which we are past
that date.
Positions are open, and people are starting
to assess and recruit and assign women.
And so that's where we stand today.
DOZIER: Got it.
So, I guess the shorter version of that question
is, when are we going to see a woman Navy
SEAL?
(Laughter.)
BEYLER: (Chuckles.)
Well, so the short answer to that is probably
in-at the absolute earliest the summer of
2018.
So the SEAL pipeline is very long, so the
next enlisted SEAL course doesn't start until
this summer, and the officer SEAL course later
in the year.
So, of course, the assessment and selection
process is very long to even get into the
pipeline.
And then, given the length of the training,
it takes about two years.
So if we have a woman in one of the first
two classes, you still won't even see the
first one until '18.
DOZIER: And same for Rangers?
BEYLER: So, the-as this group knows, the Ranger
course is significantly shorter.
So there are-so the Army did recruit their
first female enlisted infantry woman.
She signed up.
She'll go to-she'll go to the course later
this summer.
It depends.
So, for instance, the academies, when they
graduate, there are a number of women, both
at West Point and at the Naval Academy, who
have identified that they're interested in
possibly going into these career tracks.
So, of course, they'll get commissioned here
shortly, and then they will go to their courses.
So each course is different, based on the
service and the occupation.
DOZIER: I taught at the Army War College last
year, so if I didn't ask about the Army I'd
be in trouble.
So, but we were talking about beforehand that
there's a certain fiction that women haven't
already been in combat, because in the past
decade-plus war they have.
And, Gayle, you said you just covered some
remarks that-where they-where the commander
brought that out.
LEMMON: Yeah, so, first off, good morning.
I'm really delighted to be here and to have
all of you here in an early morning.
So thank you.
Thanks to this incredible panel.
And really, for me, from a storytelling perspective,
it's been a huge privilege and really a journey
to bring a story about which I was entirely
ignorant to life, which was that, you know,
back in 2011 there were women out on nighttime
operations alongside Army Rangers, Navy SEALs,
and other Special Operations teams, you know,
seeing the kind of combat experienced by less
than 5 percent of the entire United States
military, all while the combat ban was very
much in place.
And for me, this story was never simply a
war story; it's really a friendship story,
because so many times we forget that what
we haven't seen is the connection among women
in the same way we've seen the connection
among men and that Kim has covered, you know,
beautifully for years, which is this bond
of war, which we often associate only with
men, actually has been experienced by women.
And at the end of the day, it's really about
service and sacrifice and patriotism and serving
a cause greater than yourself, and gender
is secondary to it.
And it's really now that our stories are catching
up that we're starting to see the reality
of that.
And I was at a(n) event for "Ashley's War"
paperback launch last Wednesday at the National
Infantry Museum in Columbus, Georgia, which
some of you might know, right next to Fort
Benning.
And Colonel Fivecoat, who opened Army Ranger
School to women, talked about the charade
to which we had all been accustomed of the
ground combat rule.
And I thought it was just very powerful because
the truth is the commanders in the field were
working around these rules, and, at war, trying
to figure out how to get the best people in
the jobs they needed.
And working around systems-you know, one-(chuckles)-one
of the soldiers who's here, one of the young
women from "Ashley's War," was in a job that
was coded for men for years before the combat
ban was lifted-like, officially, a female
could not be in that role when you tried to
put it in the system.
But her commander wanted the best person for
the job.
And so I think really, for me, the best storytelling
simply takes us into a world we didn't know
that already existed, and "Ashley's War" for
me was just a way to tell a story about the
fact that there was an exceptional group of
soldiers who answered when their country asked
well before they officially were there.
DOZIER: Allowed to do it.
LEMMON: Correct.
DOZIER: And of course, if you were an MP and-
LEMMON: Absolutely.
DOZIER: -escorting a convoy from one-point
A to point B in Iraq or Afghanistan, you were
frequently under fire and having to fire back,
so.
LEMMON: Absolutely.
And also, the MPs have long been integrated,
which is something I think doesn't come-military
police, for folks who aren't super-familiar
with this conversation, right?-have long been
men and women, and women have been leading
in that arena.
And so I think that sometimes we talk about
these issues as if, you know, we just discovered
them yesterday night at 11 p.m. when the truth
is that many of these conversations have been
going on for years, and women have been very
much a part of America's post-9/11 wars.
DOZIER: Agnes, you did some of the studies
on this, including studies of certain organizations
like the Marine Corps that didn't want this
integration to happen-were on record saying
we want to exclude certain jobs to women.
So what were some of the drawbacks that people
brought up?
SCHAEFER: Well, so RAND did a large suite
of work on this, and we did work for many
of the services as well as some work for Juliet
on the standards piece.
And we didn't, you know, look so much at drawbacks,
per se, but we were really focused on implementation
in much of our work.
And as a result of that, we sort of focused
on lessons learned.
So this is not new, and we have had these
previous waves of integration, of not just
women but other out-groups such as gays and
lesbians.
And there are some similarities between those
out-groups and those previous waves.
So we tried to draw out some of those lessons
learned, especially from previous occupations
that were opened, such as engineers, aviation.
And what we found is that we really didn't
do a very good job at documenting that process
and identifying those lessons learned.
So we really emphasized to the services that,
as they do this, they really need to focus
on monitoring this implementation along the
way so that they can identify issues quickly
and adjust course, and that they can learn
from the process.
So the process needs to be flexible enough
for them to be able to adjust along the way.
We also looked at lessons from foreign militaries.
And one of the major things, especially with
the Marine Corps work, we really tried to
emphasize-initially they came back to us and
said, well, we have this goal.
If we're going to do this, we have this goal
of very large numbers.
And we empathized to them that nowhere in
the world are we seeing large numbers.
We're talking-
DOZIER: So nowhere in the world that has done
integration are you seeing large numbers of
women in a combat role.
SCHAEFER: That has done this, right.
Yes.
So single-low single percentages.
Those are the types of numbers we're talking
about.
And in the special operations community, that's
even smaller.
And so we emphasized to them that, you know,
if you're trying to define success in this
integration process, and you're defining that
based on numbers, you're setting yourself
up to fail, because the likelihood is so small
that you're going to be able to, you know,
recruit these large numbers.
So and that's-you know, we dug into that a
little bit more.
And that's-there were two main reasons the
numbers were so low in foreign militaries.
This may not be the case here.
It may be different.
But in foreign militaries it was because women
weren't really interested in these positions,
and secondly they couldn't make the standards.
So they were twofold there.
DOZIER: So that brings us back to you and
the question of, as the policymaker, do you
have a quota of women that you want to try
to absorb into the combat roles?
And how do you keep people from-the mantra
I keeping hearing over and over, I'm conscious
of the fact that there are four women up here
discussing this, so I've got play devil's
advocate-I keep hearing from male officers:
You just know that there's going to be pressure
on the bureaucracy to lower the standards
to make the numbers.
BEYLER: Right.
And so we heard that also.
So the short answer to the question is no,
there are no quotas and there are no goals.
I want to come back to it.
I do want to make a point, though, about the
Marine Corps.
I think what gets lost in this a lot is that
there's this narrative that the Marine Corps
was opposed to integration.
And I don't think that's true.
As somebody, again, who's-as a retired Marine
myself, and who has lived this, and have watched
the Marine Corps, the Marine Corps did a significant
good-faith amount of work here.
And I think it's important to kind of recognize
it.
They asked for exception, but a very discrete
exception.
So the Marine Corps actually recommended opening
armor, opening artillery.
The Marine Corps recommended opening the vast
majority of their positions.
And they requested from the secretary kind
of a very discrete exception in infantry and
long-range reconnaissance.
So I think, again, that's really important.
And the concerns that the Marine Corps raised,
again, all of the services-the Air Force,
the Navy, SOCOM-had very similar.
So the Marine Corps was not that far off from
everyone else.
They were just the only ones that chose to
request an exception.
So I think that's an important point that
gets lost.
But with regard to the standards, yes, we
hear that all of the time.
And so that's why when you look at Secretary
Carter's memo and he has his guiding principles,
he specifically talks about, one, right, the
need to make sure that we have the right standards,
that they're occupationally specific, that
they're current and they're operationally
relevant because, again, that's the core,
the standard of everything that we do.
And then once we-that was why it was so important
to review and validate the standards, because
now we have an ability to kind of definitively
stand behind a standard that's unemotional,
that we can explain and articulate, and it
is what's required to do the job.
Recognition also, right, that the number of
women that are going to want to do these jobs
is small, and then the number of women that
can meet the standard beyond that is even
smaller.
So there's a full recognition that the numbers
may be very, very small, or not at all.
And that's what the secretary said.
So equal opportunity doesn't mean equal participation.
We recognize there may be very-you know, very
small or there may be none.
So how do you guard against that, right?
By having a solid standard that everyone-
DOZIER: And are you publishing that standard,
so that everyone knows what it is and can
tell if it's changes?
BEYLER: Oh, yeah, absolutely.
So all of the services-well, let me back up.
So all of the services have-this is, again-I
don't want to-the services have had standards.
But we've never drilled down in the manner
that we had this time over the past three
and a half years.
So each of the services, again, went through
every single occupational standard.
And they clearly defined what the standard
was for entry into the occupation, and then
also what the standards are for not only an
entry-level soldier, but also then a sergeant.
And then the standards for a sergeant first
class or a gunnery sergeant are different
than the standards for a PFC.
So they have laid out very clearly in their
manuals what are the standards for accession-we
call them accession-and then the standards
for retention.
So those are out there.
I would also say that they have institutionalized
the process that we went through over the
three and a half years, because they learned
a tremendous amount on how to do this right.
For instance, right, the direct ground combat
role said you could close an occupation of
women if the vast majority of women couldn't
do it.
So what did that mean, right?
That was very subjective.
And so now it's a definable standard.
Does that make sense?
DOZIER: It does.
It does.
BEYLER: OK.
DOZIER: And of course, the critics out there
are going to say, all right, well, let's see
it in operation.
LEMMON: Yeah, and just one to that point.
It was really fascinating, I covered the opening
of the Ranger School to women.
And I was in pre-ranger in March, I guess,
and then in Florida and swamp phase in August.
And you know, I went to write one piece, which
was just sort of a straight, you know, Army.
And I ended up writing a piece that had standards
in it probably 79 times, because it was the
only word anybody wanted to talk to me about,
whether a woman or a man.
Our advisors, the women who were serving as
Ranger School advisors, would come up to me
and say: We never want the standard lowered.
Make sure your piece reflects that.
And all of them I would talk to, some of whom
I had known from the process of reporting
"Ashley's War," would say: I don't care, but
no standard can be lowered.
And there were lots of questions around that.
I mean, I think that's why they brought reporters
in a couple different times, trying to show,
look, there is not going to be a different
standard.
And at the end of the day, any time humans
are involved there is a level of subjectivity,
but I think they worked very hard from Fort
Benning leadership to show that this is a
transparent process and the standard is the
thing that's most important.
And the one bit of humor is that at 4:45 a.m.-which
I know you know those mornings-when I met
some of the Ranger School leadership at the
Benning gate, this one very storied retired
ranger said to me: You know, what's amazing
is I never heard people show this much love
for the standard when I was active duty.
(Laughter.)
You know, so I think it was interesting to
hear his perspective that, you know, the standard
has always been something that's shifting.
But I think now when everything else is shifting
around it, it's even more important for that
standard to be something that everyone understands
and that is not changed for anyone.
BEYLER: Well, I do want to-to your point about-standards
will shift, right?
So equipment will change.
Requirements will change.
And so standards will change, but it has to
be-
DOZIER: So standards will change because the
equipment changes and therefore the ability
needed to operate that equipment will change?
BEYLER: Exactly.
But we have clearly defined what it takes
to be successful on the battlefield.
And the standard is derived from that.
And it's derived from what's required today.
So we do recognize there's going to be pressure.
There will people that will ask questions
about why not enough.
DOZIER: But you'll always have to be able
to drag a comrade who weight 200-plus, plus
their 80-pound pack and their gun, wounded,
out of the line of fire.
Isn't that one of those standards that just
never stops?
BEYLER: Absolutely.
We often use the example of tankers, right?
The round weighs what it weighs.
And you have to take it out of the rack, you
must have the upper body strength to turn
in the seat and load the round into the breach.
It's a defined weight, it's a defined height,
an it's a defined distance.
And it doesn't matter-I often use the term
man, woman, giraffe, bunny rabbit-that is
what it takes to do that.
And so-
DOZIER: So what about the fact that some studies
have revealed that women do have a higher
incidence of injuries after some of these
heavy weight-bearing occupations?
So you might have a high dropout rate from
these combat positions, where they might wash
out after a year or two.
Will the military find a way to absorb them
back into another role?
SCHAEFER: Yeah, I think that they're working
through that.
But what we found from foreign militaries
is that there are ways to mitigate against
those injury rates.
DOZIER: Like what?
SCHAEFER: Equipment is one of those.
And I think there-just as they were drilling
down to the standards, which I think really-this
issue of really nailing down those standards
is one of the real benefits that came out
of this whole process, both for men and women,
because they really thought through rationally
what does somebody, regardless of their gender,
need to do for that occupation?
But they're now drilling down into what kind
of equipment changes they can make, again,
both for men and women.
So for instance, carrying your pack.
You know, you can adjust the waist belt for
people who have shorter torsos, men or women,
you know, those kinds of issues.
I know they're working through, you know,
the armored plates and things like that, again,
for people with shorter torsos.
So I think they're working through those.
DOZIER: So rather than making it gender specific,
they're just thinking about integrating smaller
people.
SCHAEFER: Right.
DOZIER: But there are women-specific injuries
that I've heard about, like the hip displacement
from long marches because the hips are shaped
differently in men and women.
SCHAEFER: Right.
So again, four militaries have gone through
this process.
Some of them have integrated 20, 25-
DOZIER: Like which ones?
Since you said you looked at four?
SCHAEFER: So Canada has been integrated for
a long time.
We looked at 55 countries initially and then
narrowed down to our allies.
But so, you know, you can train women over
longer distances and longer times.
So you can sort of graduate their training
so that they're not-they're training over
a longer period of time and they're conditioning
their bodies over a longer period of time.
And that allows them to strengthen-
DOZIER: So the bones have time-I've heard
something about this-that you slowly increase
the weight that the bones are bearing so they
get thicker instead of stressing them early
and causing them to fracture.
SCHAEFER: Exactly.
And they build their core and their upper
body.
So-
DOZIER: But that is slightly changing training
and standards.
SCHAEFER: It is.
It is.
So there is a tradeoff there.
You know, they-four militaries have kind of
had them train before they enlist, or before
they start some of these combat occupations.
So you could do that training ahead of time.
DOZIER: And so that brings us back to the
question that I heard brought up, for instance,
for SEALs and BUD/S, you've got to now add
in a women's room, women's quarters, et cetera.
There's an added cost associated with equality.
There's an added cost associated with this
extra training that you're talking about,
and these equipment changes.
Is that worth it to the taxpayer?
BEYLER: And so, first, I think that there
is a lot of discussion that there's added
cost, but when we actually had-when all of
the services actually looked at that, what
they found was there really wasn't.
Most service members live in rooms right now,
they're barracks, they're not open squad base.
So actually, there was very little on the
facilities side of the house that had to be
done-
DOZIER: So they're not in a room full of a
bunch of bunks, like we've seen in the old
movies.
BEYLER: Exactly.
So the only-for instance at BUD/S, at the
SEAL training school out in California, they
just had to build one new restroom.
So that was the extent of the facilities modifications
that needed to be done.
And they wanted-they needed to do some stuff
to the barracks, but the costs there were
very minor.
And the same thing, both the Marine Corps,
the Army, and the Air Force all came back
and said they didn't need to do any facilities
modernization, that they were good where they
were.
DOZIER: OK.
BEYLER: So on the training side of the house
though, I would say that-so especially on
the special operations side, they have always
had these pre-accession courses.
So these courses have always been there.
So nobody is developing any new courses.
So with regard to, was there a cost to develop
something, no, actually, not.
And so the benefit, though, is huge for both
men and women.
We learned better ways to prepare people to
succeed at the school.
Again, so again better ways to make sure,
again, we're strengthening bone density and
bone mass, and making sure-teaching them ways
to do things so that they don't injure themselves,
use the core, the things that Agnes said.
So again, all of those benefits go to both
men and women.
DOZIER: So in the few minutes before I open
it up to the members, I wanted to discuss
some of the emotional questions that get brought
up.
Now, you're a former serving Marine.
You mentioned as we were chatting before this
that there was a little bit of trepidation
when you took a commanding role at one point,
among some of the people working for you.
BEYLER: Yes.
So I was privileged, I guess, to get commissioned
after the Gulf War.
So I was in that first year group of female
combat engineers when the Marine Corps opened
that to women.
So, of course, I experienced firsthand what
it was like to integrate into an MOS that
had been completely closed.
And what I found was, same thing, right.
So there was a lot of emotion, a lot of concern,
a lot of people calling my Marines to express
consternation about the fact that they were
being now led by a woman, and what the concern
was.
But I think, like, my own personal experience
was there were a lot of myths, there was a
lot of confusion.
But once they understood who I was and what
I did, and that I did exactly what they did,
everything was fine.
So we see that in the special operations community.
We see that across the board.
When we first started talking about this in
2010, we saw a lot of those same concerns
across the Army, and these misunderstandings
of what a woman could or could not-
DOZIER: Misunderstandings or misconceptions?
BEYLER: Misconceptions, actually.
Yes, thank you.
That's better.
Of what they could or couldn't do.
And I think-again, I felt-once you get there
and they get-they understand, and they see
you, and they see you operate those things
over time go away.
DOZIER: So how about the other two sort of
lightning rod questions, how men respond when
a woman is under fire and what happens to
esprit de corps when you have women in the
mix and all of a sudden you've got guys flirting
with women, et cetera?
These are two things that are always brought
up after the first beer when you get a group
of special operators together.
LEMMON: Well, maybe I'll just make a couple
points on this.
First one is, and as this came up in the interview
with General McChrystal when we were working
on "Ashley's War" is that women have been
in Delta for a long time.
Right, so a lot of this-
DOZIER: In Delta Force.
LEMMON: Right.
And so, you know-
BEYLER: Clandestine.
LEMMON: Right.
And quietly, and obviously.
But you know, he brought that up.
Is like, you know, this is not a terribly
new conversation.
But the second thing that I think is really
important is that oftentimes I don't think
we give enough credit to men alongside whom
these women are serving.
And it was something I saw in two years of
working on-you know, trying to talk, and talk,
and talk to people who had been on the front
lines in the special operations community,
some Rangers who had done 12, 13, 14 deployments
in the post-9/11 wars, with a country that
barely knew people were doing one, right?
And you would talk to them.
And what they would tell you was: I want somebody
next to me who is competent, who is skilled,
and who will make sure that they can do the
job.
And if you, you know, pay your rent out there
night, you earn your seat on the bird, period.
And I think that, you know, the demands of
combat, the very life and death stakes of
these wars, erases so much of this discussion
that goes on in nice rooms in, you know, cities
where power goes on when you flip a switch
and the roads are smooth and there's infrastructure
that works, right?
When you're in a very tough parts of the world
when there is a very real war going on, what
these guys were focused on was can you do
your job, will you slow me down, and do you
make a difference out there every single night
and find what we need?
You know, one of the MPs who was in-military
police-who's in "Ashley's War" was telling
me the story about the SEAL team she was working
with, that actually wasn't terribly excited
to get her when she first showed up.
But you know, one of the first night out she
found the intel item they were looking for
in a baby's wet diaper in the quarters that
would never have searched, which mean that
they found the person, they got the thing,
and everybody got home safely without having
to be out there any longer.
And for the SEALs, you know, then they train-even
when there were regulations about when there
were regulations about whether women could
fast rope or not, they actually trained their
CSD to fast rope because they were like, look,
if you're going to be on mission with us,
then you need to know everything we do.
And we decide if you're ready.
And so I think what you see is people who've
seen a lot of war, which is a huge percent
of a 1 percent, are much less focused on these
kinds of discussions, and much more focused
on whether you can deliver on the battlefield.
And I don't think they get enough credit for
that.
DOZIER: And, Agnes, you were-in studying the
different militaries, we have to bring up
the Israeli example, they took women out of
their combat units because the men fell apart
when they saw the women injured.
SCHAEFER: Yeah.
I mean, there-a lot of people put up the Israeli
example as kind of the poster child.
But they have a lot of constraints on their
women as well, in terms of rules of engagement
and things like that.
And they couldn't be on the frontlines and
those kinds of things.
So you can't-it's not directly analogous to
what we're talking about here in the U.S.
But I mean, we definitely covered and studied
this issue of cohesion, because that was a
major concern across the services, because
they were concerned that if cohesion deteriorated
that would impact mission effectiveness.
And what we found is that really, you know,
during these previous waves of integration
of women into these MOSs, there was no degradation
of cohesion.
And the reason for that is that really it
was this focus of task cohesion.
People were concerned about whether you could
do the job or not, regardless of whether or
not the person to your right or left is a
man or a woman.
And so, you know, that task cohesion was really
the center.
People don't necessarily need to like each
other to work together, but they really care
about whether the person can do the job.
And this gets back to the standards piece,
I think.
So this is why standards are so important.
DOZIER: So the survey-the SOCOM survey that
you did, when you asked, you know, what do
you feel about women joining combat units,
and there was a highly negative response,
was there a way to differentiate between who
had served alongside women and who hadn't?
SCHAEFER: Yes, we found that.
And this is actually very similar to the work
that we did when we were looking at, you know,
the repeal of "don't ask, don't tell."
We looked at cohesion issues and we did a
large survey then, which at that point it
was-you know, they couldn't openly admit that
they were gay or lesbian, but we were able
to find a way to survey them.
And we found that, you know, when we talked
to service members, those that had served
along with women, in higher headquarters in
particular, and in the case of "don't ask,
don't tell," those who had interacted with
gays or lesbians, were much more amenable
to the fact that this would be OK.
And so this is-this is very typical of when
you, you know, integrate these outgroups.
If you've had contact with them, you tend
to be more-the survey data indicates that
you tend to be more amendable to that.
DOZIER: OK.
Well, it's 9:00.
So at this time, I'd like to invite members
to join our conversation with their questions.
A reminder that this meeting is on the record.
And also, please speak into the microphone
that are in front of you, and state your name
and affiliation.
Please limit yourself to one question and
keep it concise to allow as many members as
possible to speak.
And while people think of their questions,
I will ask one more.
Selective service.
Now that combat roles are open, is it time
for every young woman to go into the Post
Office and sign up for a potential draft?
BEYLER: So what Secretary Carter said is that
the issue of selective service has got to
be part of a broader national discussion that's
not just DOD.
So we're-we think it's time to have that conversation.
We're prepared to do that.
But that's-
DOZIER: OK, well, saying let's have a conversation
is not stating which way you think the conversation
should go.
That's very careful.
BEYLER: Oh, absolutely.
And the secretary's been very clear to say
this is outside the purview of just the Department
of Defense.
And so we're not there yet.
That's something we absolutely need to look
at, but again it's beyond just this very discrete
issue.
So we need to make sure that we take everything
into consideration before that decision is
made.
DOZIER: So, let's see, I wanted to ask members
to tilt their placards up when they have a
question.
I haven't done one of-ma'am.
Q: I don't know if the mics are-
DOZIER: Can you lean into that mic?
Thank you.
Q: Sure.
Sure.
So I'm Jen Leonard.
I'm with International Crisis Group.
Thank you so much for your comments.
It's not an issue I dug really deep into,
but tracking in headlines.
We've talked a lot about standards, everyone
meeting standards.
I'd be great to hear from you whether anecdotally
or research, evidence driven, about exceeding
those standards and unique qualifications,
and whether and how in your research, in terms
of looking at allies, et cetera, there have
been bit of evidence that have shared with
you why women might excel at a particular
category, set of issues, resilience, troubleshooting,
et cetera?
If there's not, where are we going to track
that too?
Thank you.
DOZIER: Who would like to take a stab at that.
BEYLER: Or I can.
So, yes, a lot of people talk about a concern
about don't lower standards, but you're absolutely
right.
So we identified places across the board where
perhaps the standard was too low and needed
to be raised.
We use often the airborne example.
The pack weight had been historically 45 pounds,
and that had been around since World War II.
That's not reflective of what you need to
carry on today's battlefield.
So that was an example of a physical standard
that actually needed to be raised in this
particular case.
Now, with regard to the things that you were
saying, kind of more on the cognitive, resilience
side of the house, so for instance in the
special operations community there are-they
do test and assess people for decision making
skills, emotional stability, all of that type
of stuff.
But those are already standards that have
been in place, so again, right, but there
are certainly areas where women will excel.
And we'll see that, hopefully, come out as
we move forward.
I don't know if you want to add anything to
that.
SCHAEFER: Yeah, so the data on this is really
kind of mixed.
And this is why we emphasized to the services
that as they do this they really need to monitor
where there's progress and see where they're
seeing those areas.
And you know, in deficiencies they may be
able to, you know, do things to help them.
So yeah, unfortunately it's very mixed.
DOZIER: OK.
Sunil?
Oh, Laura.
Q: Thank you.
Laura Liswood.
Three years on DACOWITS, so some sense of
this, and 13 years a reserve sergeant Metropolitan
Police Department.
DOZIER: And can you remind people what DACOWITS
is?
Q: Oh, yes, the Defense Advisory Committee
on Women in the Services.
It's been around since the Korean War, and
has looked at various elements.
One of the elements that we looked at was
women on submarines.
And some of the out-group objections to blacks
on submarines, you could have just taken the
language out of that and said why women shouldn't
be on submarines-unit cohesion, too close,
wives don't like it, et cetera, et cetera.
My question is, in addition to this issue
of the value added of diversity, which is
getting more and more play in corporations
and things like that, and therefore tracking
that, which I think could be incredibly interesting
to see different perspectives, do you see
that there's going to be any diminution, increase,
around issues of sexual harassment and issues
of that nature?
DOZIER: Because these women are in units that
have never had women before, or something?
Q: Yes.
And so is it more of, oh, now we respect them
and we understand what value that they have,
et cetera, versus, well, we have these close
quarters and we have these issues?
BEYLER: Oh, sure.
So I would say do we expect an increase?
I certainly hope not, but I think we recognize
that that's something we need to look at.
That's what each of the services-to the point
that we were talking about surveys before-that's
why all of the service-you hear a lot of discussion
about the SOCOM survey-but all of the services
did surveys of one sort, right?
Why?
Because we need to identify where there are
those misconceptions.
And then we need to development training or
we need to make sure that explain where those
things are incorrect, so we don't have that,
and as well to identify any potential issues
that need to be addressed.
But we don't view this issue as anything-you
know, sexual harassment and sexual assault,
it's not tolerated in the department.
It's not acceptable.
And so this is no different than any other
effort, and we view it no differently.
DOZIER: I was going to say, Gayle, can you
point out some of your folks in the crowd
who-
LEMMON: Yeah.
And there are two things I want to just get
out that we were talking about before.
So the program, they have the cultural support
teams, which was a very benign name for a
pretty groundbreaking concept, was created
by Admiral Olson, who was the first Navy SEAL
to lead Special Operations Command.
And you know, I had CSPAN caller the other
day say that, you know, is this part of the
feminist agenda?
And I said, well, I don't think Admiral Olson
was known for his feminist agenda.
I think he was really focused on the security
gap that his forces were facing in the field.
And when I had the pleasure of talking with
him in the process of reporting, he was asking
me about these soldiers, the young women who
are here, who were part of this team.
And he was asking me what they were like,
and I was filling him in, because he had retired
just before the program had been in full swing.
And he said, so they're just like the men?
And I said, yeah.
He said, you know, what I look for in special
operations is physical fit problem solvers.
He said, people want to ascribe all kinds
of superhuman traits to the special operations
community, but that's at the core of what
we're seeking.
And I think that was really important.
And to Laura's point about African Americans
and other integration, it was really interesting
talking to one of the Rangers who did pre-mission
training with the soldiers in "Ashley's War."
And he was very skeptical when they said he
had to go train girls-that was his official
assignment from when he was at Benning at
go down to Fort Bragg and-or, to go to Bragg
to train members of this team.
And you know, really at the end of eight days,
this guy who by no means would he care about
any kind of equality or agenda, you know,
that is not his world, you know, he said:
You know, I looked around and I thought, you
know, these may be one day be our own Tuskegee
Airmen, right?
Like, these people who are going to make history
and no one knows they exist.
And I do think that there are a lot of parallels.
And it's hard to see that in the moment.
I think it's hard for all of us who chronicle
it to see it in the much wider picture.
But I think 50 years from now, this moment
will look very different than it does right
now.
DOZIER: Oh, and-
LEMMON: And I wanted to just point out, there
are three of the soldiers who are in "Ashley's
War" who are here, and maybe you could just
stand up for a quick moment, yeah.
Q: Hi.
My name is Amy Sexauer.
I'm still active duty captain serving at Fort
Bragg.
DOZIER: Oh, sorry.
Microphone, please.
Q: Oh.
Hi.
Captain Amy Sexauer, still active duty Army,
serving at Fort Bragg.
Q: Captain Rachel Washburn, also serving at
Fort Bragg.
Q: Captain Meghan Curran.
I'm in the Massachusetts Army Reserve now.
DOZIER: And can I put the three of you on
the spot?
Have any of you encountered sexual harassment
when you were in these unique jobs, when you
first entered them?
Q: I think, to Gayle's point, we don't give
enough credit to the men in this conversation
a lot of the time.
I think that what we have to remember, especially
with the groups that we worked with, the special
operations community, they're consummate professionals.
And I think from my personal experience I
never saw anything to that effect.
And I really just-I think that that conversation
is not-is not addressed as much, that we need
to give more credit to the men in these situations.
And they are there do a mission and we were
there to enable a mission.
And it's almost as simple as that.
And a lot of this other conversation really
doesn't matter when you're in a high stakes
environment.
So that's my personal experience.
I don't know if-
DOZIER: Thank you very much.
LEMMON: Can I just add one thing?
It was really fascinating.
When I was working on-actually, I was just
telling Laura Sullivan this-when I was working
on "Ashley's War," you know, it's Washington,
so you don't talk about what you're working
on very much.
And occasionally I would.
And I'd say it's a special operations story.
And people would be like, oh, that's awesome.
Oh, I love "Lone Survivor."
And I love "American Sniper."
And you'd say, oh, and there are women in
it.
And it was like crickets.
And inevitably, the next question from men
and from women, was: Oh, is about rape or
PTSD?
And that was really eye opening for me, the
first, second, third time I heard it.
And by the end I was kind of prepared, because
it is absolutely urgent that the issue of
military sexual assault is front and center,
100 percent.
But when the valor story is missing, it affects
the rest of the conversation about service,
period, whether it's male or female.
DOZIER: But I thank Laura for bringing it
up, though, because that's one the reasons
that DACOWITS was originally founded, was
to represent women in the military writ large.
So it's a question that needs to be asked,
but it's great to have it just knocked on
the head, especially by somebody who served
out there.
Sunil.
Q: Hi.
My name's Sunil Desai.
I'm a retired U.S. Marine as well, infantry
officer.
I love the book.
I read the whole book and was intrigued by
it.
And I appreciate everything that I've heard.
I agree with pretty much everything.
And just wanted to make two small points.
Just my perspective.
You know, I married an Army officer who could
do more push-pullups, pushups too, that most
of the Marines that I knew.
And so I respected that, amongst a lot of
other things.
But the first point would be, regarding the
standards, and I never bought into the idea
that that was some of the reasons that women
shouldn't serve in combat roles, even when
I was a young officer.
But one point that didn't come up is, while
there is a pass/fail standard, I mean, you
have to meet some bare minimum, the standard
still exists on a scale.
And the military, in addition to the requirement
for, you know, tactical execution on the battlefield,
there's this inspiration that comes from the
people who can achieve even more, right?
And I think even the women in the book, you
see that from them.
They really admire people who are super fit,
and even more than necessary.
And so there's an element of that that should
be added to the conversation.
I mean, the senior-you've spoke with some
of these special ops leaders who are physical-I
mean, well-beyond, even as they get older
they don't hold themselves to the sliding
standard that will allow for the aging.
They hold themselves to the original, the
highest standard.
And that's admired and valued and respected.
And then the one other-just a small one.
And you touched on it with your last question
about the draft, and I have a daughter now
too.
But I think beyond that, this subject, and
the experiences, speak to the even broader
question of what's happening not only in our
country but in our society writ large, just
in terms of how families are evolving, how
work is evolving.
And there's several other current books that
are hot in the CFR world, whether "Lean In"
or "Unfinished Business," right?
And then there's another one called "The End
of May."
So I think all these dynamics are happening.
And they all have to be thought of holistically
together if we're going to get to the right
answer for everybody.
DOZIER: So one of the things I hear you saying
is that physical fitness might be one of the
ways just to put all doubts to rest, if you're
more fit than everyone else.
But going back to this question of participation
in society and are we uneven-it's the question
that Ash Carter doesn't want to be the only
one asking.
But do we need women in the draft to follow
through with this-you know, if you're going
to allow women to be in combat roles in the
military, shouldn't they be part of the wider
communities-while serving the wider community?
I guess I'm stumbling around on this one,
because it's such-it's such a-like, I can
see my own parents would have freaked out
about it, but then you look at some of the
discussions brought up by people like General
Stanley McChrystal, that shouldn't we have
at least a wider national service?
So where does that stand, that discussion?
BEYLER: Well, right, again, that's the crux
of the issue, right?
We need to have a larger national discussion
on, right, public service, national service,
and where do we need to go from there.
I think from our perspective, right, we have
an all-volunteer force, and we're meeting
the requirements that we have right now.
Now, whether we have a draft, or don't have
a draft, or whether they expand Selective
Service, or they don't expand Selective Service,
we think certainly we need to be part of that
discussion.
But it doesn't-we are-we have what we need,
and we have great people coming in.
And that was what Secretary Carter was kind
of focused on, on the all-volunteer force.
He didn't want to restrict his ability to
recruit to only half the population.
DOZIER: But isn't that, in a sense-well, it's
ducking the question, that if you're going
to make this a touchstone of your administration
that you fought for this level of equality
for first having gays in the military and
then allowing women to go into combat roles,
why not follow it through with, and we believe-if
we're backing these two principles, why not
take a stand on having women in Selective
Service?
BEYLER: So, right, I understand the question.
I guess-I guess we're-again, where we are
is we're at-we're at the beginning of that
discussion.
And I think it's just-to kind of take a position
on it before we've actually even had the full-blown
conversation is probably premature.
LEMMON: But one thing I think is so interesting
is that we talk about equality, and I think
it's also really about talent, right?
It's about finding the right pool of the right
people for the right jobs.
And I think that's the national security discussion.
That's the national security question.
It's not about social programs, right?
I think it's about security gaps and about
having the best force.
And I think the draft question is fascinating
because what-the Selective Service was abolished
in '73, and then brought back in 1980 when
the Russians invaded Afghanistan.
And, you know, that was a long time ago now,
and think about how much war has been fought
since then.
I think whole conversation should be updated.
You know, should 18-year-old young men have
to register?
Should 18-year-old young women?
What are the options for-I mean, you know,
one parent told me, I would much rather have
my daughter defend my country than my son-(laughter)-you
know?
I mean, parents come up to you all the time
and tell you sort of very colorful things.
But, I mean, I think it goes to the fact that
it's a sort of an outdated way of viewing
a world that has fundamentally shifted.
Because, to your points, you know, about looking
at things in siloes, this is a much bigger
conversation about a world that is on fire
in many different places, with a shape of
a threat that has changed and, I think, an
international architecture that hasn't changed
with it, and, going to that, a national infrastructure
that hasn't really kept pace with the time.
So how do you think of the broader question
about how you defend and protect and serve?
DOZIER: So you're say that the policy was
really changed because it's about getting
access to talent for the mission at hand rather
than an issue of overall fairness and equalizing
the playing field.
BEYLER: Oh absolutely.
Secretary Carter was very clear about that.
He was about recruit-about the all-volunteer
force.
He said, you never know where your next Olympic
athlete is going to come, so why would I voluntarily
just cut my recruiting pool in half?
It made no sense to him.
DOZIER: Agnes, in your study of other militaries,
did you find-were there other militaries that
draw from the whole pool of the population
in terms of a draft?
SCHAEFER: Yes, yes.
And, you know, the reason for integrating
these combat roles was different across the
countries, too.
Many of them were forced to.
They had equal opportunity issues, lawsuits,
things like that.
So it was interesting because-you know, it
was interesting to see those various reasons.
And some of them thought that, you know, this
was the right thing to do for equality reasons.
We took a different route.
And so, you know, their strategies have been
different, too, that kind of shaped the way
that they actually implemented this.
And some of them had quotas, which we found
actually didn't work.
They never met them-(chuckles)-because their
numbers were so small.
And, you know, that sort of set back the process.
DOZIER: So what were the numbers?
Like, what can we expect?
What was an average of numbers of women in
combat roles?
SCHAEFER: So in no-yeah, in none of the countries
that we looked at did we find anything above
low single percentages in these-in these roles.
DOZIER: You're saying 2 percent or 9 percent?
SCHAEFER: Like 5 (percent).
Six (percent) was the highest.
So-
BEYLER: Canada's at-
DOZIER: Absolutely.
SCHAEFER: Yeah.
I mean, some of them are just very, very low.
BEYLER: So, for instance, Canada, which integrated
their infantry almost 25 years ago?
SCHAEFER: Yes.
BEYLER: Twenty-five years ago, and their numbers
hover around the 1 percent range right now.
So, again, but those, right-so that was informative
for us.
And back to your question about the standards,
so we need to kind of continue the discussion
about low numbers or no one is fine, right,
because you have to meet the standard.
And so, right, we have to continue to make
sure that people understand that we are fully
comfortable with having low numbers.
DOZIER: So, to play devil's advocate, that
it's interesting you're-Gayle just talked
about you want to open up all of the force
to look for talent, but then it's only filling
1 percent, or will probably only fill 1 percent
of those roles.
BEYLER: Right.
DOZIER: To play the devil's advocate, it's
a lot of churn and a lot of expense to look
at this, to open everything up, to get only
1 percent of those roles filled.
BEYLER: Well, you could say that, or, again,
we don't know who's out there that may-we
have no idea what it's going to look like.
So you don't know what those young, young
girls in high school are capable of and wanting
to do moving forward.
So we may see increased numbers.
Again, as we look at training properly, like
better ways to-and fitness, and building that
body mass, looking at BMI and bone strengthening,
you never know.
We may actually have more numbers in the United
States.
LEMMON: It was fascinating.
So I was at West Point in the fall, and one
of the things that was really fascinating
there was, you know, you come in and you're
supposed to give this talk.
And I said, well, I just have a question for
you, you know: how many of you want to go
into-into infantry and to-and, you know, hands
shot up.
And just to think that they are on the cusp
of this change, right?
There are young women at West Point who would
come up to you and say, I've always felt like
there were two tiers: jobs that, you know,
everybody could do, and then jobs that, you
know, women couldn't, and I have always to
be in infantry.
There were a couple of the-(chuckles)-young
women who were soldiers in "Ashley's War"
who actually didn't-enlisted and didn't know
that women couldn't be in the infantry.
Or ROTC cadets who were, you know, at the
top of their ROTC corps but actually couldn't
be in infantry when they came out.
And so, you know, you see all kinds of what
I would call inefficiencies in the system
in some ways, right, that are being leveled
out.
But I have never heard anybody talk about
huge numbers, but is there a talent pool out
there?
You do see it.
DOZIER: Well, hey, I went Wellesley.
I'm just-I'm trying to-(laughter)-this is
not a very skeptical audience, so I'm trying
to channel the skeptics who are out there.
LEMMON: No, absolutely.
And all the questions-all of these questions
come up.
And I think it's really important to have
discussions about them, because otherwise
people feel like, well, gosh, you know, they're
just having a conversation divorced from reality.
And the truth is you just want to have a reflection
of what's already happening.
SCHAEFER: So, if I could say quickly about
the cost piece, we actually ran a very detailed
cost analysis in our Marine Corps work.
And we looked at attrition rates for women
and, you know, how many women you would need
to bring in to keep the infantry at the same
level it is today, and those kinds of issues,
and we found that it's less than 1 percent
of the overall personnel budget.
So, again, this-I think that there's this
misconception that it will be very expensive.
And that mirrors what the other services have
found, too.
DOZIER: So less than 1 percent of the overall
personnel budget, what are we talking?
Because you guys have big budgets.
(Laughter.)
SCHAEFER: Yeah, I can't-it was very small.
I mean, I-sorry, I can't think of the-
DOZIER: Tens of millions?
SCHAEFER: It was-I think it was-yeah, I'm
not sure.
But it was-overall, in the scheme it was very
small.
DOZIER: Very small.
SCHAEFER: Yeah.
DOZIER: Sir?
Q: Damon Porter with the Association-
DOZIER: We can't hear you.
Q: I'll start again.
Is it this one?
Thank you.
(Comes on mic.)
Damon Porter with the Association of Global
Automakers.
We know oftentimes that policy decisions are
not made in a vacuum.
And clearly there's demonstrable evidence,
as we've discussed today, why women should
be in combative forces.
But can we talk a little bit from the historical
perspective?
We've raised the issues of physical standards.
How much, such as Title IX, were shaping the
ability of demonstrating the physical dexterity
and ability of women to serve in combative
roles?
And I guess the other point to that question
is, how much can women in combative forces
help shape the policy discussions outside
of armed services, such as equal pay?
DOZIER: So suddenly we have a whole bunch
of questions with only six minutes left.
LEMMON: I know.
(Chuckles, laughter.)
Always happens.
DOZIER: So I'm going to ask a couple of people-yeah,
couple of people to do a couple questions
in a row.
Can we take your question?
Q: Hi, yes.
I'm Sally Adams, and I'm here on behalf of
the Women in Military Service for our America
Memorial, called WIMSA.
And we're the only memorial that honors all
women across all services in the nation.
And in 2014, a DOD report came out and said
that DOD spends about $90 million on 87 military
service museums, and not one of those is dedicated
to women.
And I just wanted to know, during this time
of unprecedented progress in the military,
if the time is ripe for support for this institution
as well as other memorials and museums that
honor women?
DOZIER: OK.
And one more?
Q: Oh.
Hi, good morning.
My name's Christine (sp).
I'm an undergraduate student at Georgetown
University, but I just transitioned out of
the Marine Corps.
I was a corporal.
I transitioned out in July.
I was an Arabic linguist.
And right now at school I do a lot of research
on understanding the Muslim world.
And we've talked a little bit about the unique
advantage that women bring to the battlefield.
And, especially as the decision's already
been made for integration, I hope to switch
the conversation to, like, OK, it's decided
now, so what are we uniquely going to bring
to this-to this arena.
So my question is, do you think women will
provide a unique advantage?
And how can we capitalize on that, specifically
when we're talking about women in encountering
violent extremism, which I know a lot of NGOs
and think tanks are focusing on?
And so I'm wondering if the DOD specifically
has looked at how we can integrate women specifically
to capitalize on women's unique skills in
that arena.
DOZIER: So we have three questions and three
minutes left.
Starting with that one, unique skills that
women can provide, are there specific things
you're recruiting them for within combat roles
that help in those areas?
BEYLER: I mean, I think-I think that goes
to one of the earlier questions, right?
So there are-there are-women and men, there
are differences, and so perhaps there are
the things can women can bring to the discussion.
And I think it gets to "Ashley's War."
There were very unique skillsets where the
Special Operations community, you know, realizes
they need help.
So this was just really-this was a recognition
of what was actually already going on in the
fights and in Iraq and Afghanistan.
So, I mean, to answer your question, yes.
But again, that's part of that entire discussion.
That was the reason behind all of this.
We wanted to be able to use the skills of
the women that were out there.
DOZIER: And the Title IX question?
Sorry, go ahead.
LEMMON: Title IX, I think, is fascinating.
One thing, if-I noticed a couple things that
were across the board on the soldiers who
were part of "Ashley's War," and the Rangers
were really taking specifically the direct
actions that were taking, you know, the most
fit.
And as one Ranger said, if nobody else liked
you, we did.
You know, they were looking for people who
were ready to go out and be fit and fierce,
and be able to keep up on those kinds of Special
Operations missions.
And almost all of them were track athletes.
Almost all of them had been raised by fathers
who had always treated them the same as their
brothers.
Or, if they had no other siblings who were
brothers, they were held to the highest of
standards.
And athleticism and sports was very much a
theme across the board.
And they can talk to you about that more afterward,
but you really did see that across the board
in terms of always having been fit, always
having trained to a very high standard.
And Amy, who's here, actually played high
school football all four years.
She's going to be mortified when I tell you
that-(laughter)-and didn't want to after the
first couple years, but little girls would
come up to her at games and say that she wanted-they
wanted to be like her.
And that-it was sort of hard to quit after
that.
So, you know, I do think Title IX very much
played a role in the physical athleticism
and the opportunities.
DOZIER: You had something to add.
BEYLER: I wanted to add one quick point.
I think something that was fascinating for
me is about-you ask, how are these women going
to affect-a lot of the senior men that were
involved in this conversation, right, they
have daughters.
And a lot of their thinking on this issue
was formed by those daughters and what they
wanted to see, you know?
Their daughters were phenomenal, and why shouldn't
my daughter be able to do this?
And many of those daughters are serving in
uniform as young captains and lieutenants
now.
So I absolutely think-and they may not be
on the cusp.
They may not be, but they are out there and
they are absolutely the ones that continue
to inform this discussion.
I think that's fascinating about all of the
dads.
DOZIER: And last quick point, the women institutions
or museums memorializing women in the military.
BEYLER: Right.
So, absolutely, WIMSA does some phenomenal
work, and we thank you for what you do.
I can't exactly, but budgets are tight and
we certainly support the work that you do.
It's fantastic.
Q: Thank you.
DOZIER: Thank you very much.
I want to thank the panelists for answering
some tough questions and showing the public
out there that the tough questions have been
asked before enacting this policy.
And thank you all for attending this session
on "Women in the Armed Forces: The Future
of the Military."
That concludes this CFR session.
(Applause.)
(END)